I've been telling you for 11 months but
it's finally been confirmed Brad Wright
will not be involved in any new Stargate
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so yeah going back 10 11 months now I've
been saying that Amazon we're not
particularly excited about Brad Wright's
script for any new Stargate series and
that well I've been saying it pretty
much for the last three or four months
so he most definitely will not be
involved in any new Stargate series
while he's been on Twitter he's had a
few things to say and he has now
actually himself confirmed that he won't
be involved in Stargate he's also
confirmed a few other things though for
one one of the things I was saying was
that MGM were very keen for Brad Wright
to move forward with the Stargate series
now Amazon were telling MGM a little
over a year ago that they were not
massively excited about Brad rights
projects they wanted it to be a lot
bigger and they were thinking rather
franchise more than just a one TV show
so MGM actually did look at a second
script they did a lot of preliminary
work they did a lot of artwork they did
a lot of storyboarding things like this
with the plan that as soon as the Amazon
sale was finalized they would green
light Stargate they would green light
Brad Wright's Stargate if you haven't
subscribed already please do and like
and share the video wherever the hell
you want also if you enjoy the content
and you want to support the Channel
please hit the join button also we have
our sister Channel Star Trek side so we
do lots of little best bits from the
lives and lots of other fun silly little
videos so please go and subscribe to
science
but as soon as the sale went through
that plan went to kaput Amazon actually
put the hammer down and said no we've
been telling you for ages now we don't
like Brad Wright's script and we want to
move forward in a different direction
now Brad writers kind of confirmed this
as well he does mention that there is
now a new regime in charge of MGM and
that you know they just don't seem to
want what he's doing and that his script
is just Gathering dust
So reading between the lines there I'm
basically saying the MGM we're very keen
to push forward with this script Amazon
aren't
so this is very much very bitten a
little tiny little bit sweet for me in
that I've been telling this for a long
time and there are people that have
called me a liar for it I would say
don't shoot the messenger but there are
a lot of people that have said I'm full
of [ __ ] I don't have any sources MGM I
don't talk to anybody and it's all the
big lie just to get clicks I would say
that if you actually know which I earn
off YouTube you'd realize it's really
not worth the effort and it does upset
me a little bit that I get accused of
being a liar don't get me wrong it's not
very nice particularly considering how
much work I do put into putting these
videos out for you and all I really want
to do is share information with people
that love this show as much as I do
so it's been confirmed what I've been
saying now hopefully the rest of what
I've been saying is also going to turn
out to be true and we're going to find
out about Stargate by Christmas maybe
the early New Year
another piece of interesting news though
to go with that is the Stargate is
trending on Twitter again
this is a show that's not been on our
screens for over 12 years but in the
last 12 months it's been trending on
Twitter on and off reasonably regularly
this is the main reason why Brad Wright
actually tweeted out in the first place
just put Sanders saying guys this is
amazing you're trending on Twitter again
this is incredible now he then says I'm
not the place to ask for news on
Stargate I don't know and I've also been
telling you that for 10 or 11 months I
think Amazon have been freezing him out
of any discussions about Stargate for a
very long time but he also says that
when Stargate does come back whoever is
at the helm he will be just as excited
as the rest of us because at the end of
the day Brad Wright is a massive fan of
Stargate he loves the project that he
was involved in for like 20 years so why
wouldn't he now that's going to come
into my other point that is this a
mistake by Amazon now we've discussed
this over and over again on the channel
but let's be honest it is a huge mistake
Amazon could have easily said to Brad
look we don't like your script we want
you to go in a different direction or we
don't want your script but we do want
you come on as showrunner
come on and be the captain of the ship
help us to create a new franchise like
you've done before we're going to bring
in a new team around you and some new
writers some new blood we want to go in
a slightly different direction but we
want you to be the main man this would
have been a very easy way to make all of
the skaters very very happy and instead
Stargate is going to have a new captain
in the ship somebody that according to
my sources we're all going to be happy
with but are we really or is that just
something that's being said again I
don't know how much information
sometimes I'm getting from just like
insiders I don't know how much
information I'm getting on purpose from
Amazon I don't know for certain I keep
getting told a lot of the time that I'm
just a shill and I'm being given
information that Amazon want me to know
and hey sometimes I might be I don't
know
if this is something that is just being
banded around and rumored on purpose by
Amazon that we're going to be very happy
with whoever this new showrunner is then
they're really going to have to follow
through with that because we will have
to actually be happy with it and to be
honest if it's not Brad right it's gonna
have to be somebody really really
amazing or they're going to have to
prove their worth and by that I mean
fans might not watch the show
fans might have to be won over by the
show rather than just giving us somebody
we actually want and letting us get
excited about it for six months or so
while they make the damn thing something
that we will in our Millions watch on
the very first episode
Amazon to me are making their lives
Difficult by saying no Brad right but
hey I just have to hope that whoever is
in charge of Stargate knows their ass
from their elbow and they're all right
from their Towery and if they do there
is a really good opportunity here to
make an amazing TV show and an amazing
franchise I would love to see movies TV
series and games this is one of the most
loved sci-fi franchises it is the
sleeping giant of sci-fi so let's get it
back on our screens as quickly as we can
so guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think of this news is this
something we could just now move on from
no Brad right that's the end of it it's
not happening or actually is this
something we should be trying to fight
back against because at the end of the
day Amazon do listen to us they like
their money and they know that keeping
us happy will make them more so should
we actually just take this as a sign
that we need to fight hard
tell me what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe that
the Bell notification it really helps us
out also if you enjoy the content and
you want to support me hit the join
button because that really helps us out
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
maybe maybe a few years ago the the
cancellation of a series might have
signified the end uh period and we would
have all been packing up and going home
but when the studio and the network uh
and and Robert and I were talking about
what we're doing going forward
it became a
became an opportunity to launch into
movies and that's exciting for me as a
writer producer but uh but also as a fan
because I I loved making Continuum and
thought it allowed us to take Stargate
SG-1 to the next level
we can do that with Atlantis too and I
think it will happen and
we're already planning another Stargate
sg1 movie so this when you include
Stargate Universe which is a new series
that we're working on right now that is
exciting to Robert and I it puts
Stargate uh here where we're seeing
words like canceled but Starkid is
really in the stronger place than it's
ever been before as a franchise you've
got Universe you've got Atlantis movies
you've got sg1 movies you've got
Stargate worlds that's a that's a lot of
strong legs for for uh
for things called Stargate to stand on
and and that's exciting for me as a as a
writer producer and I really hope and
and believe that the fans are going to
feel the same way
[Music]